la tâche de bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur rt france vous êtes en direct
de beyrouth où d'abord première question
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui sur
place dans la capitale libanaise
c'est encore tôt pour le dire
aujourd'hui on se prépare une grande
manifestation au j'espère qu'il y aura
des centaines de milliers de gens et
qu'ils vont crie encore une fois encore
et encore leur désespoir leur colère
contre la classe politique qui non
seulement et négligente mais qui ce rôle
le terrorisme madame li mobilisation
anti gouvernementale donc aujourd'hui à
beyrouth beaucoup de monde sont attendus
dans dans la rue est ce que vous pensez
que cette classe politique est contesté
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
voire des mois va survivre à cette crise
c'est pas et c'est pas une protestation
contre le gouvernement c'est une pensée
contestation contre tout le système
sectaire qui a gouverné l'église depuis
plus de 40 ans c'est un système qui va
tomber pour tes aliments nous laisse on
peut plus s'offrir et peut-être cette
casse mafieuse terroristes qui nous
gouvernent
il était et il est essentiel aujourd'hui
1 qu'il y ait des changements au liban
on a vu emmanuel macron qui a été
accueilli par la foule jeudi les
libanais qui ont même demandé que
que leur pays soit peut-être placé sous
protectorat français aujourd'hui c'est
charles michel qui est attendu
sur place qu'est ce que vous pensez
justement de cette communauté
internationale qui se mobilisent pour le
niveau de 1 c'est merveilleux de voir
l'amitié internationale qui nous couvre
qui nous donne beaucoup d'amour en ce
moment à pied une tragédie pareille
les gens ont besoin d'affection et
d'amour et c'est ce qu'on ressent à
travers la visite aux petits patrons et
à travers toute l'attention nous étions
les otages de cette classe politique et
de l'iran ça fait des mois qu'on souffre
isolation totale à tous les niveaux
diplomatique économique
alors nous étions les otages de l'iran
et cette visite et les visites qui
suivent la présence de l'aide
internationale le liban est plus moral
qu'autre chose en ce moment et je n'irai
pas aussi loin à vous demander la
présence d'un oui oui mais nous
demandons je pense que la majorité de
libanais elle préfère de lenche là le
chapitre 7 des nations unies conçu à
pendant un moment
miss et protection internationale
militaire
mais même en aviser tellement nous
sommes nous sommes les otages
elle y sommes malheureux parce qu'ils
ont c'est de ce pays et de celle est il
alors du côté de l' enquête on a appris
l'arrestation de 19 personnes des
responsables du port mais également du
port et et des douanes michel ans le
président libanais a pris la parole hier
soir devant des journalistes
ils refusent l'ouverture d'une enquête
internationale comme l'avait réclamé
emmanuel macron lors de son déplacement
faut-il voilà aujourd'hui que cette
enquête pour connaître les coupables de
ce drame soit l'échelle internationale
selon vous je pense que notre président
est aussi bien être l'otage de france
vaut la houle bien il est vraiment il
est vraiment pas conscient de l'ampleur
de style et de ce qui s'est passé ce
n'est pas à lui d'accepter une
commission internationale
c'est au peuple libanais de le faire le
général michel aoun le président jalal
n'est plus acceptée
procurez-vous le peuple accepte plus
évidemment qu'il a toujours un soutien
populaire de son parti politique les
gens qu'il aime mais c'est une identité
en ce moment le la majorité du peuple
libanais demandent le départ du général
du challenge le départ des ministres du
gouvernement et du parlement
le départ de tout le monde de tous on
avait on a créé notre douleur devant
monsieur macro on lui a demandé de
ramener cette classe politique avec lui
dans un exil
je ne vais pas en france parce que nous
avons la france nous ne voudrions pas de
la france souffre de leur présence mais
n'importe où merci beaucoup en tout cas
la lingette avoir réagi avec vous depuis
beyrouth je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste politique